[Musique]
la place du tertre les moulins des
bistrots tout cela c'est mon marque mais
hier il y avait quelque chose de plus
beaucoup de monde dans les rues bien sûr
mais aussi les uniformes que des
majorettes des fanfares et somptueux se
des confréries vineuses de france et de
l'étranger
la butte fait des ces vendanges des
vendanges dont on parlait déjà en 944 et
qui donne toujours ce petit vin
qu'apprécier le moine fou laura gérard
de nerval et que nous apprécions très
appréciée aussi les rênes de montmartre
entouré des danseuses du moulin rouge
toutes ces personnes se sont rendus à
pied de la place du tertre jusque dans
les vignes du clos mômes à l'affût créé
la chanson des ventes
le maire de montmartre madame ans peut
être binage prononça le discours
traditionnel puis 160 privilégié
assistèrent au dîner officiel tout cela
n'est qu'un début la fête des vendanges
continuera dimanche prochain à 14 heures
place du temps
[Musique]